in other videos we've already talked
about the difference between distance
and displacement and we also
saw what it meant to plot position
versus time what we're going to do in
this video is use all of those skills
we're going to look at position versus
time graphs and use them in order to
figure out displacement and distance
traveled
so this first question says a 3.2
kilogram iguana runs back and forth
along the ground the following graph
shows the horizontal position of the
iguana in meters over time
the first question is what is the
displacement of the iguana between 0
seconds and 5 seconds
so be very careful it's not saying
between 0 seconds and 6 seconds it's
saying between 0 seconds and 5 seconds
so pause the video and see if you can
figure that out
well displacement is just your change in
position
and sine matters we care about direction
so it's going to be your final position
minus your initial position
well what is your final position
well we're not talking about the final
the hot the last time that we have on
the graph here our final is going to be
at five seconds
so our final position is at a positive
six meters so our final position is
positive six meters
and from that you're going to subtract
our initial position well our initial
position was at negative two meters
negative two meters and so this is going
to be equal to six minus negative two is
positive
eight meters
so one way to think about it is
net
this iguana shifts eight meters in the
positive direction and if we think
positive direction is say to the right
it would be 8 meters to the right we
could draw a number line here
so if we it's sometimes confusing
because we're talking about the
horizontal direction but we're plotting
position vertically here but we could
take the same number line and make it
horizontal and you'd have negative 6
negative 4
negative 2
8.
and so what's happening here is the
iguana is starting at negative two
and then over the next three seconds it
goes to positive six
it goes over here and so it shifts to
the right by eight and that's what we
saw right over there 6 minus negative 2
is 8.
now what about the distance traveled by
the iguana over that same time period
pause the video and see if you can
figure it out
well the the distance is the total
length traveled the total path length
but once again it went from negative 2
all the way to positive 6 over the first
three seconds and then it just stays
there
so if we think about distance
we're actually going to get the same
result even though we don't care about
direction here we just care about the
magnitude we still get the same thing it
traveled 8 meters
so it travels 8 meters so we're going to
get the exact same result
now what would be interesting is to
think about what would be different if
instead of five seconds if this said six
seconds
if this was between zero and six seconds
well then for displacement we would say
hey look we went plus eight but then
we're going to go another
negative 6.
so this right over here let me make this
you're going to go another negative 6
and so you actually have you would have
the plus 8 minus six so if you did it
for all the way to the sixth second then
your displacement is going to be plus
two meters you have the eight and then
you subtract the six another way to
think about it is you would finish at
zero you started at negative two zero
minus negative two is two
if you wanted to think about the
distance between zero seconds and six
seconds well you would have this eight
meters and then you would go even though
you're going back to zero
even so you're going
back to zero right over here
six meters you wouldn't subtract it
because the total path you travel eight
meters to the right and then six meters
to the left and so you would add them so
if you said over the first six seconds
instead of the first five seconds this
would be 14 meters let me make that
clear again displacement and distance in
both cases you have plus eight over that
first leg i guess you could say and then
when we thought about displacement we
subtracted because we're now moving to
the left we move to the left by 6.
so in the case of displacement you
subtract the 6 and you have a net
displacement
of
plus 2
but distance the total path traveled you
have the 8 to the right and then 6 to
the left which gives you a total path
traveled of 14.
let's do one more example here
a
2.7 kilogram armadillo rolls in a
straight line in the desert the
following graph shows the horizontal
position in the horizontal position of
the armadillo in meters over time and so
let's think about the same thing over
the first 24 seconds let's go all the
way to the 24th second let's think about
what the displacement is and what the
distance traveled is so first pause this
video and see if you can figure out the
displacement over the first 24 seconds
well this is going to be our final
position minus our starting position
our final position we're at 0 meters
our starting position we were at time 0
we were at 6 meters
or let me just write the numbers down so
it is negative 6. let me say that one
more time at time 24 notice our
vertical coordinate
we are at a position of zero that's
where that came from
when we started
at time zero our position was right over
here
so our final minus our starting is
negative six and you could also see that
if you just look along this line
we shifted from positive 6
to 0 which would be a shift of 6 to the
left if you made this horizontal or a
displacement of negative 6. let me draw
this on a horizontal line just to make
this a little bit more
clear
so if you have 0
4 oh 0
9 12
15 so on and so forth we are starting at
six let me do that purple color
we're starting at six we do a bunch of
stuff in between but then we end up
after 24 seconds at 0.
so our shift we went 6 to the left or we
have a displacement of negative 6. 0
minus 6 is negative 6.
so now let's try to figure out
distance
pause the video and figure out the
distance that this armadillo travels
over this 24 seconds
so this is interesting so it's right
here it starts off at position of six so
let me do it right here it starts off at
the position of six it stays there for
the first eight seconds
then from the eighth second to the
sixteenth second its position
increases by nine to get to 15.
so it does this
it goes to 15.
so this is going to be plus
this is going to be plus 9
and then on the
16th second it goes from 15 back to zero
so it goes from 15
back
to
zero
if we were thinking about displacement
we would write a minus 15 here and then
we would net these out to get to a
negative six but we're we're thinking
about distance so we want we think about
the absolute value of the various parts
of the path traveled so all of these are
going to be positive we just say hey
what is a total journey so this is going
to be plus 15. we just care about the
lengths of these arrows not the
direction
and so
9 plus 15 is 24.
so this is interesting even though the
armadillo traveled a total of 24 meters
its entire path was 24 meters long its
net shift its displacement is 6 meters
to the left and this is another thing to
emphasize this negative number this is
this is implying
direction it's saying if we look at this
number line it's saying to the left even
if it was a positive 6 because we're
talking about displacement it would
imply positive would mean to the right
distance doesn't tell you about
direction it just tells you the absolute
magnitude of the total distance traveled
or the length of the path